so visual visualizations are a powerful
means to tell a story
did anybody spot the mistake in this
slide exactly so you have to always
remember to tell the story that is the
first rule of data visualization unlike
this epic fail that somebody cat caught
on Twitter which I love that is just not
how graphs work it is important to
accurately reflect your data with your
visualization so it should go without
saying but it's always worth saying to
try and be as accurate as possible so
we're back to our rather simple
visualization who can tell me the
meaning of this it's the numbers under
10 again oh I'm sorry I thought I said
into place right so we have this this
isn't bad we're highlighting the
outliers in our data but perhaps we
think we can do better
perhaps we think if we order our numbers
this might help organize the data create
a better visualization for our users and
we've been messing around with our
visualization it's probably a lot more
complicated than this we've been
fiddling around with it for a while and
then the kind person sitting next to
your teammate says I finally have the
data ready and your visualization all of
a sudden looks like this and the viz
that you created does not work with the
real data I can't tell you how many
times I've had this happen and there's
lots of ways visualization a
visualization might not work for your
data you might have over plotting just
have too many points on a screen as it
turns out you might have under plotting
you might have too much variation you
might not have not enough variation so
one example that Springs to
mind is I was working with the designer
we had a designer doing sort of
designing stuff we had a client who had
all the data that they were doing we
were quite coding stuff up with dummy
data and then eventually you know the
data came and the designer had done this
awesome thing and there was going to be
little spark lines which you know have
they're sort of just a line chart with
no numbers on it they just give you an
indication a trend but when the data
came in there was just no trend to it
because it was population wise data and
a bunch of other reasons but that meant
that we just the page just had a bunch
of flat lines on it and it was like the
design looked amazing because the
designer had drama least like in a cute
little scribbled on it but because we
hadn't been working with actual data
when we really brought it up for real it
just looked kind of sad and we had at
the last minute to sort of scramble and
change it another thing that can happen
is you might not have this message that
you thought you did
so I was working with some other folks
and they were still working on the
analysis but they've done like some you
know initial work and we were it was a
big complicated modelling project and so
we we had a long conversation about what
was the message is going to be how are
we gonna tell this whole long story
and then I worked on it for a while
built all these visualizations and then
the data came through and we'd like
mapped it all out and they were like oh
we've never actually seen it on a map
this doesn't tell the story we thought
it did and then you have to rethink and
so this is I hope not something that
happens to you not that often because
you're working with your own data all
the time you're not necessarily
designing visualizations for other
people but I think it is an important
lesson so I wanted to I wanted to
include it in this crowd so hopefully
we've covered the two the two easy
lessons first try and be accurate and
use the real data next we're back to
this again I'll ask the question I was
asking before
what is this plot showing
to slice it is showing how many numbers
are between 23 and 44 and the point I
want to make here is just the
visualization is not enough you have to
have a title you have to have the
explanation you have to lead your
readers along the way so you need to
prompt your audience that might be your
colleagues your boss the public at large
as to what they're looking for and
there's a really good quotes from
journalism I think here and from writing
don't overestimate the public's
knowledge but don't underestimate their
intelligence so don't assume that they
have all the background that you have
that you've brought to this amazing
analysis that you've done but also don't
assume that people are stupid you don't
have to spell things out painfully you
don't have to dumb things down I think
perhaps the more like six inked version
for us is assume an intelligent
impatient reader and we have all been an
intelligent impatient reader and I think
if you've ever emailed somebody be like
hey you know how's the how is your
analysis looking and you get this back
and you're like thanks chart title no
labels on the axes a bunch of numbers in
a spreadsheet you know this is this is
this is gonna take you a while to like
dig into somebody else's spreadsheet
you're lucky if it looks this nice you
know oftentimes it's like even more
impenetrable than this and so I think
it's I think always assume when you're
trying to convey your results to
somebody to ensue an intelligent
impatient reader at the very least break
out the answer you're trying to give
someone label your axes give the chart a
title and write that succinctly
explenation of like what the person is
meant to take away from this so telling
your data story you should be as
accurate as possible you should use your
data and when telling your story assume
an intelligent and impatient reader so
we're creating a visualization we're
creating a story
there's a famous thing in writing like
show don't tell and there's a lot of
stuff on the internet about whether
that's really how writing works but the
point is sorry I've got my slides out of
order the point I think in data
visualization is that you want to show
and tell you have a message to tell you
have something very specific you're
hopefully trying to convey in most cases
but showing that act of like a somebody
looking at the data and seeing it for
themselves is that is that really sort
of that connection that means that they
don't you didn't they didn't just hear
it they didn't just listen to your
arguments they saw your evidence and
they now know that for themselves and
they can go on and communicate your
message and that's where I think the
visualization is very important is that
show and tell aspect and at this point I
did want to sort of just highlight the
difference which is probably pretty
obvious between exploratory and
explanatory exploratory is what we're
all doing every day it's that analysis
and explanitory which is what we're
really talking about today is that
reporting and that talking about the
results of your findings so the very
first question when you send before you
send somebody that Excel spreadsheet
with a random chart in it or you make
some massive presentation to your whole
company or you put up something you put
up a dashboard or whatever it is you
have to ask what is your message is it
something as simple as sales in the
southeast region or up or is it some you
know complex scientific discovery about
how multiple processes in the brain work
and you know how you can do this new
analysis and you've like you know
won a Nobel Prize who knows either one
of these it's the same process for
trying to communicate that well along
with what and these I think this is sort
of an iterative loop you have to code
sort of consider them all at the same
time is why why are you telling this
person why does this person care do they
care because they're going to make a
decision about it quickly do they care
because they're trying to learn
everything that you've learned are you
communicating to your colleagues are you
communicating
to a higher-up that just wants a brief
analysis of what you're doing you know
why are you even sending that email or
writing or making this presentation in
the first place and then who were you
talking to and those what the message is
why you're doing it and the who you're
doing it to are probably all going to
sort of feed into the same two into the
same question of what's what's the
message here and if you can answer that
well you're a really really long way to
to getting this right so we've got our
data we have an impatient reader and we
have the impatient reader can also be
you in six months time don't forget that
any of us you've ever written code as
that's always true and then and then
you've got the message like what what
are you trying to say to who and why so
I if any of you ever met me before or
you were at the tutorial yesterday I can
be fairly verbose and some people are
outloud thinkers some people are
internal thinkers but well I when I try
and do this properly I often think of a
message as like as like a decision tree
it sort of it gets more and more
detailed and I try and I often start
down here because that's where I like to
live but I try and work hard to like
boil it up and make it more succinctly
making this version of a t-rex are we
doing the super beautiful shaded nuanced
subtle version of the t-rex you know
that long message that we're trying to
convey are we doing this version of the
t-rex which is about our where my art
skills lie are we doing this version of
the t-rex are we doing this version of
the t-rex where you just tell people
that the standard deviation along X is
19 and then they'll figure it out this
this is these are the same pieces of
information and this is another good
reason to always visualize your data
this I got this
Alberto Cairo tweeted tweeted this out
as the Anscombe asaurus if any of you
are familiar with an screams quartets I
think it can now firmly be replaced with
the Anscombe asaurus
so so which version of the message are
you telling these are all valid versions
of a Tyrannosaurus Rex it depends on
what you're trying to tell to who why
and so on and I think there is sort of
two there are two ways there were two
ways that I in my career this is not an
absolute segment all there are two ways
that I've approached data visualizations
and I'm that if one is narrative in
pieces and the other one is like a
custom is a custom visualization and
merit of in pieces is basically kind of
some kind of report way where you're
just trying to visualize everything you
show you're working along the way and
you provide just sort of a graphical
overview in that same way you might a
presentation and I am I can show an
example of one of those later if we have
time but today I'm going to focus on a
custom visualization a kind of what
would you call it like what's the word
when you do one one big piece of viz
that really captures your idea and you
and and that and that's what the reader
takes away with them and so I brought a
couple of examples of this
the first one is this rather awesome
visualization of a history of sumo
wrestling from 538 it's got this
interactive slider every trail on here
is a it's a different sumo wrestler you
can switch the X and y-axis to their
height or that's weight and weight
height and weight and so on and so forth
and you can really mess around with it
and it's quite fascinating if you
highlight over a dot you'll see some
information about each sumo wrestler in
this rather epic interactive from the
new york times we see voting
demographics broken out into really
really really specific demographics so
there's a little legend that is too
small for you guys to read on the bottom
here of race so pink is white green is
black purple is Hispanic
and that yellow is Asian or other and
then you know this this person here this
is white man aged 65 and older with
postgraduate degrees in Maryland and so
if I was to just highlight the post-grad
turnout is on the y-axis here we can see
this thing anyway this is a super fun
visit I could I really enjoyed voting
election data as a new US citizen with
the election coming up I've got a little
bit uh a little bit excited so so there
we have that and then yesterday we
started to talk about the Gapminder
example this is a fairly famous example
of statistical visualization from Hans
Rosling where you can see all of the
countries of the world changing over
time and one of one of his main messages
is that back in the 50s when the term
sort of the third world and the first
world were calling coined countries were
sort of distinctly separated but over
the last 50 60 years countries have
really started to merge together in a
sort of blob of development and
everybody's sort of moving up and to the
left in this case
and this is fine but this this is better
as from the true
so here we go first the Nexus for health
life expectancy from 25 years to 75
years and down here
an axis for wealth income per person
four hundred four thousand and forty
thousand dollars so down here is poor
and sick and up here is rich and healthy
now I'm going to show you the world 200
years ago in 1810 here come all the
countries Europe from Asia red Middle
East green Africa south of Sahara blue
and the Americas yellow and the size of
the country bubbles showed the size of
the population and in 1810 in this
pretty crowded down there wasn't it
whole countries were sick and poor life
expectancy will be old 40 in all
countries and only the UK and the
Netherlands was likely better off not
much and now I start the world
industrial revolution makes countries in
Europe and elsewhere move away from the
rest of the colonized countries in Asia
and Africa they are stuck down there and
eventually the Western countries get
healthier and healthier and now we slow
down to show the impact of the First
World War and the Spanish flu epidemic
what a catastrophe and now I speed up
through the 1920s and the 1930s and in
spite of the Great Depression Western
countries for job towards greater wealth
and health Japan and some others tried
to follow but most countries stay down
here now after the tragedies of the
Second World War we stopped a bit to
look at the world in 1948 1948 was a
great year the war was over Sweden
topped the medal table at the Winter
Olympics and I was born but the
differences between the countries of the
world was wider than ever
United States was in the front Japan was
catching up Brazil was way behind Iran
was getting a little richer from oil but
still had shortly
and the Asian Giants China India
Pakistan Bangladesh and Indonesia they
were still poor and sick down here but
look what is about to happen here we go
again in my lifetime former colonies
gained independence and then finally
they started to get healthier and
healthier and healthier and in the 1970s
then countries in Asia Latin America
started to catch up with the Western
countries they became the emerging
economies sameen africa follows some
africans were stuck in civil war and
others hit by HIV and now we can see the
world today in the most up-to-date
statistics most people today live in
them all right so a fabulous history
lesson from Hans Rosling and the
difference between this just turning
away and what we just saw is that
fabulous narrative that he brought along
where he he paused at different points
and he explained what was going on and
he told you the little narratives that
the little vignettes that were leading
you through that story and brought you
along it's not enough to have a fancy
visualization although you'll get people
will be perfectly happy if you make this
but if you really want to convey that
meaning that meaning it you probably see
in your data you see all of those little
details because you've been slaving over
your numbers forever other people don't
see that even if it is your colleagues
you know your analysis is the work that
is that you know best
and if you want to communicate it you
have to go that extra mile obviously
there's a difference between shooting
off an email and you know making some
kind of presentation once a year that's
like a capstone for you know whatever
piece of work you're going to be doing
but I think that I think this this for
me or Hans Rosling does a really nice
job of bringing that point out and so I
want to rewind to the sumo and the
voting things we saw from the New York
Times I cheated a little bit that's not
they didn't just throw you in at the
deep end of the interactive on both of
those projects what you start with is
this this is the sumo one we start with
the history
they've set this in context of various
historical events then they zoom in and
like give you a one little narrative
about one particular legend in sumo
wrestling they zoom out again to the
modern master bringing it up to the
present hopefully something you can
relate to they sort of start to help you
see the trends in the data now they
introduced the fact that there's some
interactive portions that are going to
be bringing other elements of this out
and then finally you're left back at
where we started with the ability to
explore this yourself but without that
context and that work that they did to
just take you through some sort of views
on this interactive that you built
really helped like you then be able to
dig into it and pull out what you want
to pull out similarly with the New York
Times this is the original article that
it started with it starts with a giant
blob explaining that about 60% of
citizens voted half over just over half
for Obama then it breaks it out by race
introducing you to the the color
differences then by education
introducing the next split that they've
put into the data then they've put the
gender into the data next the age and
finally the state and then at the very
bottom of all of this you can go and
click on this link and get into that
interactive and you'll notice what they
said here find yourself in these charts
and maybe I'm an egomaniac but I don't
think it's just me I think I it's a very
natural instinct to want to go and find
yourself in data to click your race your
sex your gender when you look at a map I
think one personally I think one of the
reasons I've been trying to find
research about this so if anybody does
have a paper about this then I'd be
really interested to read it but like I
think one of the reasons that maps are
such a popular popular visualization
even though they're oftentimes not the
best visualization for a data is because
we like to find ourselves in data and
and
so you know a lot of times you I might
put you know people say I we want a map
it's like okay well map isn't necessary
the right scene but maybe you put a map
next to something that better highlights
the point because you're sort of taking
that compromise between something that
engages with somebody and something that
and something that's really highlighting
the message you're trying to make and I
don't know how many of you noticed it
but Hans Rosling did this too he wound
back to 1948 and said you know and
Sweden won the medals and this is the
year I was born and that was a really
nice way of just personally like taking
that moment to personalize the data and
maybe maybe next time you look at that
you'll find your year and see how the
world was you know when you were born I
don't know but like it's that little
thing that makes that connection between
you and the reader so I've got about 15
minutes left and I wanted to I'll save
some questions for time at the end but I
wanted to take a little bit of a dive
into into doing this with bouquet and
this is super brief and I've posted the
code I've posted the code that you're
going to see online so you can check it
out later and I hope that we can
continue this conversation online if
it's something that interested in so
yesterday at the tutorial we went
through the very basics of how to use
bouquet to do simple things like make a
scatterplot to maybe change the
formatting on the axes to maybe start to
style it a little bit and add a hover to
start to use a linear interpolator to
make that size bubble to use a color
mapper to map the regions add a legend
to the plot and then this still working
yes and then you know use interactors in
the ipython notebook to build in that
interactivity but what we can do to you
know to try and bring together the the
lessons from today is we can we can make
that effort to help lead people through
at least introduce them to our
visualization
so this is all written with a bouquet
server app and it you know it starts a
little bit blank and welcome I've
totally ripping off hands rustling here
I spend a lot of my life right but
ripping off hands well thing but he
makes pretty good examples so I've
highlighted the poor and the sick and
the rich and the wealthy now I've I've
brought the legend in on the right and
I'm noting that countries are colored by
region now I'm bringing the countries to
the foreground and noting that they're
sized by population and on the next
slide we click into it auto forwarding
through the through the gears and you
can pause and you can go back and have a
sit now this is not the most slick
example by any stretch of the
imagination but it is very achievable
and so I wanted to show you some of the
code and of course I didn't make this
big hang on sorry I wanted to show you
this some of the code to do this because
it's it's a very it's not that hard to
do something that simple and it's
possible to make it much more slick but
I wanted to show that it is achievable
sorry yes yes definitely one second
great right
so that readable yes okay so if you were
in the tutorial yesterday this will
hopefully look familiar I have a method
that makes a plot I'm using that because
I'm gonna do it
over and over again I'm gonna zoom down
to the bottom I have some buttons and I
have an X button a previous button this
is a super janky way to do this but it
works and that's the point right what
can you hack together that works because
we don't have unlimited time to mess
around with JavaScript so we have an X
button a previous button and then we
have a global variable frame and next
just an increment and decrement
decrements frame then I have this very
very ugly method here and it just says
if frame is 0 do this if frame is 1 do
this it's not rocket science any one of
these frames any one of these frames
should look like
fairly straightforward bouquet quick
bouquet code that you could you could
make just as an individual plot in a in
a cell so I don't want I'm not going to
to dwell on it too much the hopefully if
you're interested in doing something
like this then you can piece it together
between reading this code looking at the
tutorial notebooks from yesterday and
this will all make sense the one thing
that I did want to to highlight is that
I picked the crudest way of doing as
possible you'll notice that the whole
page kind of refreshes when I when I
switch between the buttons and I did
this by replacing all of the children of
the layout this is a great place to
start if you're trying to use bouquet in
this way just to replace like the whole
layout when you're switching something
up you could do much more subtle things
where you just made things appear and
disappear when you kept more of the
context and I think that would be a much
more pleasant experience but that's it
that's a nice place to start
so this is what I wanted to say when
you're telling your data story be as
accurate as you can with your data use
your data to do your design work or you
will weep as you get closer to your
deadline
think about upfront what the message is
what are you trying to say why are you
trying to say it who you trying to say
it to and craft that narrative
accordingly assume an intelligent and
impatient reader highlight illustrative
examples like we saw in the sumo case
and in in in in in all the cases we
looked at where you just pick out a
specific detail which helps the user
connect to what these different points
that you're looking at mean and if
necessary like don't forget to add some
documentation about how to use it if
it's not obvious immediately obvious
yeah so I've got a little bit of time
for questions if anybody Thanks and we
want to get the questions on the
microphone so it can be recorded so
who's got questions my question is who
can take a picture of the slide because
I definitely want to tweet that all
right thank you get things going
fish for information so when you say
document how to use can you kind of
describe like other than comments good
good ways that you found to do that sure
I think that it falls into two
categories one of which I don't have an
example of which is to I'm sure many of
you like have gone to a page and had
like those are like an arrow pointing to
like you know there's a drop-down over
here or something like that in an
example in something I should know
hopefully this won't take too long to
load in this example here there's
documentation about what their topic is
like top and bottom but just in the next
to the visualization there's a small
selector state to see more information
so I've put that information about how
to use it like writing in closed context
with the visualization where the sort of
more broader picture stuff is is a way
in the actual website itself the other
way to do it is is is like how the 538
folks did which is to switch the view if
you're going through this kind of
progressive thing to switch the view to
try and give the the user a sort of clue
is so that's what's happening another
choice I made on the on this example was
I made the choice to start the animation
so that you know your eye is going to be
drawn down here to the slider so there's
like I think it's more about wherever
you can make it a subtle clue that's the
best way because then it's going to be
intuitive you know people aren't going
to notice that they've had to look for
something and where where other if that
doesn't work try and do a big arrow
other questions I'll ask one so um I
thought it was very insightful to talk
about your exploration being different
than your explanation and I'm wondering
if you have hints of when you transition
from one to the other
without kind of manipulating the data or
is it just when you have to present to
somebody when you have to present to the
VP or is there a certain time when you
start it's as soon as you're not just
talking to yourself yeah I think because
as soon as you're out of your own head
you're having to convey a whole bunch of
implicit knowledge that you don't you're
not even aware that you've built up so I
think these skills in general like maybe
you work really hard on something you
crave for a big presentation but I think
they help you just communicate better to
your colleagues on like a daily basis
because we all have stuff you know in
built in assumptions every time we say
something what are the questions my
built-in assumption that you guys are
finding for questions anything else that
you wanted Sarah
so or no questions up front trying to
get the back you mentioned just you
mentioned a story where people looked at
the visualization later and said and
realize it didn't tell the story that
they wanted to tell mm-hmm
in scientific papers of course we
separate results from discussion and
results are very factual and there's no
narrative and then the discussion would
try to weave that into a story but the
benefit of doing something like that is
that you have to show all the data and
you even have to show things that may
conflict with the story that you want to
tell mm-hmm whereas if you're choosing a
visualization often the temptation is to
discard the things that don't jive with
the message we want to share and how do
you you know from a journalistic
perspective there's always in the
ethical obligation to share data that
tell the opposite so what are your
thoughts on how to balance that ethical
obligation with trying to tell it nice
narrative I think that's a really I mean
my husband's a science journalist and so
we spend a lot of time thinking about
that topic and we spend a lot of time
thinking about the fact that sciences
seems to be mostly not repeatable
and that there you know
in science in general I don't think
we've gone far enough to present our
results make them replicable make them
shareable and maybe more
you know nature's taking some steps
recently to publish ipython notebooks
and there's like there's interesting
things happening right and I think that
actually if you could build a
visualization that not only helps
discuss your results but presented your
results right if you could not make that
separation maybe you would be not
editorializing but actually being
clearer and plain about your your
results I think that often time results
aren't as compelling as obviously
there's a push in publishing to make
results more compelling than they are
because you want to publish and I think
that words can do that more easily than
a stock graphic another fun fact about
visualization is that so you can use
this for good
if I you could this is tiny I'm sorry
you could say there's some correlation
here I think most people would see some
correlation here the more I make these
axes bigger the tighter that bubble is
going to be and the more strongly people
are going to perceive a correlation the
closer in the less people are going to
perceive a correlation now that the
correlation hasn't changed it's just the
axes that have changed and so you know
there are things like that that you
could use for good or evil to tell your
message in either way and that is where
you know what's the what's the right
answer there there isn't one there's
just trying to be you know fair with
your data I've started just randomly
wandering on the topic did I answer your
question yes right
election results they do that all the
time where in order to emphasize a point
that they want to make they may
portrayed things in a certain fashion
and it's just you know something that we
since we deal with data all the time
it's important for us to try to convey
the truth and not necessarily just one
side of the story I also think it's
important to try and remember to step
back from like the canned visualizations
that we do when we're doing exploratory
analysis scatter plots histograms box
plots or whatever to step away from that
and try and think of something that
really expresses what you're trying to
express so I saw a paper you know it was
a machine-learning paper and they done a
image plot of the Pearson correlation of
a bunch of features I'm like this is not
my specialty anyway it was just
basically like a heat map and us you
know and like you're so far removed from
the the point of what this whole thing
was about that it's like you're not
close to the message so like when I was
working on that I tried to I mean I saw
the point of what you know the
statistical analysis that have been done
but that visualization didn't really add
anything to somebody coming to this to
try and understand the points so we had
to think of fairly novel and new graph
to try and like actually just bring the
fairly obscure thing of like picking out
machine learning features and bring it
back to the sort of fundamental question
that you were trying to answer so I
think there's also space for that so I
really enjoy I really enjoyed what you
said so far and one of the things I was
one you a comment a little bit more upon
was when you look at static grass
there's a long legacy of what looks good
what communicates well to people who
don't see it all the time
well you get these interactive graphs
you've shown some nice examples but
where do you see the the kind of best
practices or the who's doing a really
good job of showing interactivity people
who don't look at graphs all the time so
they can really understand what's going
on Rosling is a great example are there
others so I think I picked out three of
my favorites today which is 538 I think
there's a really nice job and most of
538 stuff is static with just really
modest interactivity New York Times does
a bunch of Interactive's and you know
and we showed Hans Rosling and I and I
but I think and this came up from there
was there was a question in the audience
yesterday about you know when when to
use Interactive's and when not to I
think the whole point of the talking
about the snapshotting and how this you
know something like this like led you
through the whole thing is that the only
way to understand that massive blob of
data is is the snapshot first and that
is what's really teaching you about this
thing and then there's this opportunity
to explore it and so and really the
exploration is probably the me and the
data kind of thing so I think I think
what you asked this question yesterday
and I was thinking about it overnight
like why use an interactive charting
library versus a static one and I think
I think what what boquete lets you do
and others may do but like I just I know
voce is that it it you start you use
botella lots for example to make static
plots and you're doing your exploration
but when you want to move into more of a
storytelling component maybe you're not
even using the interactivity in a way
that feels like in
activity right like jumping between
these points is really just like jumping
between slides but what you've used is
you know interactive features to sort of
help bring people through like static
snapshots in a story so yeah I mean this
is something I'm still thinking about a
lot to try I don't have a lot of
messages lots of good people have
written about this Alberto Cairo and
Andy Kirk and the whole open vids conf
and there's lots and lots of good
information online but yeah I'm still
learning so so with that I'm gonna go
ahead and thank Sarah we have a
10-minute break we can do around the
pots